so um I mean I have a bias for the word
inspire inspire you know
um
to me to to make that an action rather
than a result you know to inspire I love
that which is you think how to it's it's
a it's a it's a standard by which you
have to live by right did you inspire
someone today yeah you know
um I have a thing I I I I've abandoned
it lately but I had
um two fish bowls in my room
and we can calculate you know we know
the average lifespan we know our average
lifespan it's you know whatever the
number is 78 or whatever it is so you
can actually easily calculate the number
of
months weeks or days that you
statistically have left on this planet
right
um and so I bought a bag of marbles and
one marble represented each week that I
have left on the planet
and I filled up the exact number based
on the statistics in one fishbowl
and at the and it's it's more it's more
inspiring than Doomsday
uh I mean it's just statistics yeah no
no but at the end of every week I would
ask myself
um I actually got it down to the day but
at the end of every week I'd say was
this a week worth living did I do
something to inspire someone
and it's my own standard and if the
answer is yes I move it to the other
Fishbowl if the answer is no I throw
away the marble because I wasted it
right
um and uh and that's why I love the word
inspire I believe it is a standard to
live by and inspiration is what how we
make other people feel you know it's not
did you do something I did something
good today I gave money to charity
that's not what it is it's how did I
make someone feel and did they feel
that their their life is even better
even for five minutes because of
something because of their interaction
with me right
um and then genuine care I think is the
second part of it right yeah
Inspire the world
to lead with genuine heart right with
genuine heart and again I think that
sets you up for values like you know and
it's proprietary I've never heard
anybody talk about genuine people talk
about Innovation and you know Integrity
like those are generic words
but genuine heart is something you can
own and so how do you amplify a genuine
heart
um what are the standards of of of
leading with genuine heart what does it
mean to lead with genuine heart what are
the values that mean that are you giving
out a genuine heart award you know to
the person in each property who
exemplifies and by the way the way to do
that is to ask their teammates to vote
for them not come from leadership like
who who inspires us to lead with genuine
heart to the degree that we want to be
more like our own colleague
because a peer review is actually more
powerful than than a review from from uh
from up on high because really we're
working for one person's approval where
a peer review is my team loves me and
we're not angry when somebody wins that
award I deserve that because I voted for
him because I voted for him right
um
um and it sets a standard for the rest
of the team so so I think uh peer review
where we allow our own people to choose
who within our group who within our team
has inspired us
to lead with genuine heart and the irony
is they may not be your best individual
performer
but they're probably your best natural
leaders
it doesn't necessarily always line up
with with performance